at this point in my life i have enough
passive investments that i make multiple
million dollars a year uh without doing
much and over the last nine months i
struggled mightily with this fact
and it was because i had completely
removed myself from the portfolio of
businesses that we own which do about 85
million dollars a year
in revenue and now i have nothing to
sell you what i want to talk about today
is kind of what that nine to 12 month
journey was for me kind of living in
pseudo-retirement and the single thing
that has gotten me out of it because i
was candidly you know pretty depressed
and i couldn't find a way out because
i kept looking for the next goal post
right
the the second championship ring because
the desire was that that ring would
somehow make the first one more valuable
you know at the time of this making you
know we've now crossed about a nine
figure net worth i'm 32 my wife's 29
and it's hard for people to to
conceptualize this but like i really
don't need anything like i need nothing
as much as that has been the goal for a
long time was to need nothing it also
introduces a new variable of needing
nothing which means that there is
nothing for me to do what i want to walk
through is the kind of single phrase
that i've been repeating to myself over
and over again and has become the chorus
in my mental dialogue to myself it's
around work
and so what i realized after
pseudo retiring
and not really being involved in the
businesses and having them continue to
grow and continue to pump out cash flow
is that you know the first thing that
god gave adam and i'm not religious but
i think that there's there's power in
this in this story the first thing that
god gave gave adam
was not eve it was a job it was work to
do
and as humans
we
wither without adequate challenge
we are formed against something else
right the hotter the fire the harder the
steel as a person who desires to
continually grow i had removed the
challenges in my life and felt stagnated
or stagnant as a result of no challenge
i had to re-examine a lot of different
pieces of my life which is why do i work
and up to this point the reason that i
worked was for the outcome it was for me
to build up my net worth to create
financial freedom to be able to have all
the time to do the things i wanted to do
but in so doing i removed the things
that i actually wanted to do which was
challenges which was
work that i found meaningful with stakes
that are real the single chorus that i
continue to revert back to and i'll show
you the background on my phone
is hard work
that's it and i love this proverb in the
bible i can't remember which one it is i
think it's i can't remember i think i
want to say 14-3 our work works on us
more than we work on it that's a loose
paraphrasing but that's how i like
saying it is that your work works on you
more than you work on it and so if i
have the desire to grow i must work
and the goal cannot be to stop working
that is what most people say and i think
it's because the word work still
is has has terrible connotations in
society the amount of people who are
like man you won't have to work ever
again like dear god that sounds horrible
i just lived it i never want to do it
again
but hard work is work worth doing the
fact that it's hard makes it worth it
when you look back and when i look back
at the times that i enjoyed most in our
entrepreneurial journey was the struggle
was the times of lacking was the times
where the stakes were high and we had to
perform anyways not because of the
outside circumstances because of what it
told me about myself
we do not have values until they are
tested you cannot say you are loyal
until you have a way to cheat on your
spouse and know that no one will catch
you you cannot be honest until you have
the ability to steal money and know that
you will not be caught and then choose
not to do it anyways
and so to the same degree
i cannot grow
unless i have something to match the
ability to conquer that i have now i
can't hang up my my suit right my arms
uh my weapons just yet
and so
what's interesting is that as i've
shifted my course to this thing what a
lot of people when i share it say oh
yeah because if you work hard all the
other things will follow i'm like no no
no no you're missing it and i had to
correct this in my own head
because that's how i started it if i do
the hard work the things will follow and
that's the common thing like it's all
about the process not perfection it's
it's not about the outcome it's about
the journey like everyone says this [ __ ]
but deep down they still want the akka
and i'm telling you
removing the outcome truly has been the
most liberating thing i've ever done
and i i can't begin to tell you the joy
that i am feeling in being truly present
because the work is the goal the work is
the goal
doing a good job is the goal and so when
i find myself at the gym
sometimes i would write you know i did
eight reps when it was really seven and
a half but i'm like why the hard work is
the goal if i went up or it went down
from last week it's irrelevant how hard
i chose to work is the goal when i'm
editing a paragraph for my next book i'm
like oh that's pretty good and i'm like
you know it can be better
and then i remember hard work is the
goal and so then i dive back in when i'm
tired and i don't really feel like
giving layla the emotional energy to be
the husband that i know i should be or
that rather i would like to be i
remember the chorus hard work is the
goal and so it gives me this renewed
energy to not only be better but to be
present and so i have the opportunity to
work hard and that's really the thing is
that now i'm seeking
opportunities to work hard because the
work is the goal right now everyone's
trying to shy away society's trying to
tell us you shouldn't work it's all
about passive it's blah blah blah but
work is the goal and when you make work
the goal it allows the process itself to
be meditative it allows the process to
get you into flow and for most of us
flow is some of the best feelings that
we can have in our experience because we
truly are in the moment and so we do not
work or try our best so that we do not
work hard so that we work hard
period
because hard work is who we are and this
has been a credo that i have
i'm just beginning to internalize and it
has it is giving me more
presence
than i've ever had
and it's amazing
and i know that i will fall short
of hard work
but i will be damned if i do not try in
the present moment to work hard
and when i die
if all anyone says is that [ __ ]
worked hard
i don't know what else i would want
anyone to say because the outcome is
irrelevant there's luck there's outside
circumstances right there's plenty of
things that can affect how well you do
but if we can appraise our success
based on how hard we worked and the work
itself and only you know if you could
have done better
and if you chose not to
and i'm telling you the more times i
recite this chorus in the present moment
where i have the opportunity to not to
to finish and know
that based on the standards of others
it's excellent
but not on my own
it gives you this it takes the power
back from the world and brings it in
because i'm not allowing them to tell me
how well i did
i'm not allowing chance or luck or chaos
or circumstance or outcome to dictate
how well i did
i know because the thing is is that that
stuff
is irrelevant the only actual thing that
we can control
is the work we do
now the hard work
the work that we know that energy by the
way side note
your ability to work itself is
improvable
you can increase your capacity to work
and to work hard and to work well by
working hard and working well and so the
more work i do the more work i become
capable of and it's [ __ ] awesome and
so i'm telling you that i was so so
driven by first
the outcomes that others that that i
wanted to have to impress other people
and then i would say the second kind of
phase or season of my life was creating
outcomes that would impress me and i
feel like the thing that i'm
transitioning towards which this last 12
months has helped me make this
transition and i'm sharing this with you
because i've been to what most people
consider the mountaintop right we cross
a nine-figure net worth mind you i'm 2
000 times poorer than jeff bezos but i'm
still probably wealthier than the guys
on instagram who are flexing right i've
been to the mountaintop and i can tell
you that there's nothing there
nothing
you feel
nothing
so the same way you feel right now
truly about the amount of money or the
amount of outcomes that you have
supposedly achieved up to this point
everybody's achieved something these
things will be no more meaningful to you
the second ring does not somehow make
the first more meaningful moving the
goal post does not make the thing more
meaningful which transitions me to the
third chapter right the third season for
me
which is that the hard work itself is
the goal and that's it
and when i look at my wife and i think
uh i'm just gonna say hi rather than
saying hey sweetie what's going on how
can i help right if just like it doesn't
like it's just mental energy of just
trying harder
just and then once i try hard over and
over and over again that will become the
new baseline and then i will be able to
try harder still
and so it's been this repeated chorus in
my mind when i'm at the gym when i'm
talking to layla when i'm working on a
project when i'm making these videos
try and work hard
work
hard
hard work
is the goal
and it feels amazing
because there's nothing else
because at the end of my life at least
if i look back
and i had two lives
one life where i achieved everything
that everybody thought
i would know that i would feel the same
way i do now which is
not empty but just nothing i feel the
same as i did when i had 10 million
dollars same as i felt when i had one
million dollars as soon as i had a
hundred thousand dollars i felt the same
but if i look back and i can see that
consistently over time
i
worked
to the limit of my capacity to work true
and honest to myself and so like i said
at the very beginning of this you only
have the value if you have the
opportunity to not exercise it and do it
anyways
so you cannot be loyal unless you have
the opportunity to cheat and not get
caught and then you don't do it
that is when you have the gift of
knowing and having evidence that you
have loyalty
and so if i desire the character trait
of hard work
and work ethic
then the only way that i will be able to
have that
is to do work
and know
that i could work and stop
and everyone else would be satisfied and
i would have no negative status
ramifications because most of us work to
the point where we would have we
reversed the negative status
notifications that the outcome of the
work delivers all right so you do stuff
just enough that your boss says it's
good you do stuff just good enough that
your clients think it's good but that
means that you have the opportunity to
work harder to work better to make it
for its own sake for the sake of the
work and chose not to
and so therefore you cannot say or claim
that you know how to work hard
you work just enough to escape the
social
negative consequences
you are just loyal enough to not cheat
on your wife because you know you get
caught and the negative consequences
outweigh it you are just honest enough
that you won't steal because you don't
want to get caught and if you are only
truly motivated by the negative
consequence then you do not have the
value and so the value that i am trying
to grow in myself is the ability to work
and the beautiful thing about this is
that i get to test this every [ __ ]
day
is that i can have work that is good
enough that people will see it and think
that's good stuff and i would know that
it wasn't as good as i could have made
it but i get that opportunity again
tomorrow to try and raise the bar
and that is what i am focused on in this
season and so i love you all mozy nation
appreciate you um keep being amazing and
i'll see you guys in the next videos bye